alors que dix neuf mille personnes ont
manifesté hier contre les annonces
antique au but d'emmanuel macron quid
des aspects économiques de cette
nouvelle allocution présidentielle le
chef de l'état a relancé ses projets de
réforme mais derrière les mots d'un
président semble-t-il déjà en campagne
pour sa réélection pour quoi relancer
les réformes
alors où l'économie est en pleine
convalescence éléments de réponse avec
l'économiste jacques sapir c'est l'édito
[Musique]
jacques quel a été le contenu et
économique de cette intervention des
manuels macron bonjour d'abord et oui
effectivement on a eu une allocution qui
était très focalisée évidemment sur le
problème de la vaccination mais qui
contenait aussi des choses importantes
en économie alors en économie trois
choses doivent être retenus la première
c'est une défense du quoi qu'il en coûte
et cette espèce d'affirmation des
manuels macro que non seulement le quoi
qu'il en coûte aurait protégé les
français
mais que fondamentalement la france en
aurait fait plus que les autres pays une
deuxième chose importante celle annonce
que les réformes vont reprendre alors
bien sûr pour la réforme des retraites
emmanuel macron a dit quand la crise
sanitaire le permettra mais on voit bien
qu'il y a une annonce à la fois de la
reprise de la réforme sur l'assurance
chômage et sur les retraites
et puis un troisième point qui est
important sur la question économique
c'est justement cette espèce deans à la
souveraineté économique d'hymne à la
souveraineté industrielle café emmanuel
macron alors de tout ça quoi retenir et
bien d'une part c'est évidemment un
petit peu baroque
il ya des choses qui apparaissent assez
incohérent les unes avec les autres
mais surtout que le président est
aujourd'hui rentré de plain-pied dans la
campagne électorale pour l'élection de
jacques connaît-il du bilan de la
gestion économique du coc vide
alors en ce qui concerne évidemment ce
quoi qu'il en coûte
il faut dire deux choses pour les
salariés oui ça fonctionne et ça même
très bien fonctionné la france est le
pays qui a certainement le plus protégé
ses salariés on le voit là sur le
graphique
la france a protégé pratiquement 50% de
ses salariés
ce n'est qu'autour de 20 % en allemagne
22 % en italie
bref là effectivement la france c'est
une un quasi sans faute mais ce n'est
pas du tout la même chose dès que l'on
regarde les travailleurs indépendants
rando clé les travailleurs non salariés
est là et bien il ya beaucoup plus de
choses à dire on le voit la france
apparaît en 12e position
elle est devancée outre des petits pays
comme chypre aimable elle est quand même
devancé par l'italie ce qui n'est pas
rien par l'espagne mais aussi par
l'allemagne l'allemagne grands pays
industriels qui pourtant a mieux soutenu
ces travailleurs indépendants que nous
pourtant la france ce qu'elle n'a pas
largement creusé son déficit pour
financer tout ça au pire sur bien sûr et
gorille le déficit atteignait à la fin
de l'année dernière donc au 31 décembre
quasiment sans cesse pour cent du pib
oui effectivement nous avons beaucoup
dépensé d'argent mail encore si on
regarde un petit peu l'ensemble de ce
qui a été dépensé à la fois ce qui était
dépensé d'un point de vue budgétaire
mais aussi des aides en liquidités qui
ont été fournis par la banque centrale
européenne
eh bien on voit que la france sans être
complètement ridicule eh bien elle vient
après l'allemagne
après l'italie après le royaume-uni est
pratiquement à égalité avec la belgique
est un petit peu devant l'estrade donc
on voit que d'une certaine manière en
somme brute
on est loin d'être les premiers et puis
il faut quand même rapporter cette somme
je dirais aux chocs économiques subies
on sait que le pib a reculé en 2020 en
france de plus de 8% de 6% seulement en
allemagne
alors quand on re calcul c'était en
pourcentage du choc subi là qu'est ce
qu'on voit et on voit que la france elle
est à nouveau largement dépassé par
toute une série pays l'allemagne le
japon aussi bon en europe mais c'est
quand même un pays industrialisé
important l'italie et qu'on fait à peu
de choses près jeu
égal avec la belgique donc on le voit
bien il n'y a pas eu je dirais un effet
aussi massif que cela du quoi qu'il en
coûte
et pour une raison très simple la france
a été beaucoup plus touchés par exemple
que l'allemagne ou que le japon par la
crise induite par la coved 19 homogène
sur les réformes emmanuel macron a
annoncé que c'était reparti pour un tour
oui tout à fait tout à fait et ça si
vous voulez c'est un autre point
important de son allocution
alors deux choses tout d'abord il y a la
réforme du régime de l'assurance chômage
c'est un point important parce que cette
réforme elle avait été invalidée par le
conseil d'état
emmanuel macron a indiqué qu'il voulait
que cette réforme repasse d'ici le mois
d'octobre prochain
ça pose quand même un problème parce que
une réforme qui est cassée par le
conseil d'état ce n'est pas si évident
que cela
2 la faire passer en force quelques mois
après donc ça c'est d'un premier point
et puis deuxième point il ya la fameuse
réforme des retraites
ce serpent de mer du quinquennat dont
emmanuel macron annonce le redémarrage
même s'il a pris immédiatement soin de
dire oui mais pas tant qu' il y aurait
la crise sanitaire
alors la réforme des retraites il ya
quand même deux enseignements qu'il faut
tirer des débats qui avaient eu lieu en
le premier enseignement et c'est quand
même extrêmement important c'est que
c'est très fort qui veut annoncer la fin
de tous les régimes spéciaux conduira
nécessairement à la réapparition
d'autres régimes spéciaux pourquoi et
bien tout simplement parce que l'âge
moyen en bonne santé
si vous voulez des travailleurs est de
59 ans bien sûr pour les ouvriers il est
plus élevé pour les cadres il a encore
plus élevé par exemple pour les
enseignants le problème n'est pas là
avec pour les ouvriers ses 59 ans et au
sein de ses ouvriers
il y
les professions ou 7h est même inférieur
la maximale
si vous voulez en bonne santé c'est 57
ans voire 56 ans pour les écouter on
sera nécessairement obligé de recréer
des régimes spéciaux pour ces
professions alors plutôt que de dire que
l'on allait supprimer tous les régimes
spéciaux
vous allez nous dire qu'on allait
réformer ces régimes spéciaux
peut-être en supprimer certains mais en
recréer donc ça c'est un premier
problème qui est le deuxième point qui
est encore le plus important c'est que
pourquoi est ce qu'il y a si peu de
travailleurs de plus de 60 ans et qui
sont toujours au travail
pas parce qu'ils ne le veulent pas pas
parce qu'ils l'ont été parce qu'ils sont
à la retraite mais tout simplement parce
que les entreprises les ont licencié et
les ont licencié en priorité parce que
ce sont des travailleurs qui sont bien
payés donc il vaut mieux licenciés un
travailleur de 60 ans bien payé pour en
embaucher un jeune qui sera payée
nettement moins et donc qu'est ce qui se
passe si on rallonge la durée du départ
à la retraite
pariente ici on passa à 64 ans et bien
que ces travailleurs n'auront plus leurs
annuités et verront mathématiquement
leur pension de retraite diminuer donc
ça veut dire que cette réforme des
retraites
elle va nécessairement impliquer des
pertes de revenus des pertes de pension
importante pour une partie des
travailleurs pour les travailleurs qui
sont justement les censier avant la de
la retraite et qui constitue un cheap
quand même assez important et on peut se
demander alors pourquoi est-ce que
emmanuel macron veut faire ces deux
réformes
qui sont grosses évidemment 2 je ne
dirais pas de problèmes sociaux mais en
tous les cas de tensions sociales tout à
fait évidente mais alors pourquoi est-ce
qu'ils emmanuel macron s'obstine et bien
la réponse c'est là encore qu emmanuel
macron et rentrer en campagne électorale
il sait que dans son électorat le coeur
même de son électorat est grosso modo 23
ou 24 % de français qui voteront pour
lui au premier tour
et bien il y à une forte majorité de
gens qui sont persuadés que ces deux
réformes sont nécessaires
donc qu'est ce qu'il fait il décide de
flatter son électorat et ça c'est
typiquement une logique électoraliste et
respect er le thème de la souveraineté
économique
ce que vous êtes surpris de le voir
reprendre ce thème alors oui oui j'ai
été assez surpris et je dois dire que là
on ne peut qu'approuver une partie des
termes dont a usé emmanuel macron si
vous voulez quand il parle de la
nécessité de défendre la souveraineté de
la france la souveraineté économique la
souveraineté industrielle de la france
bien sûr qu'il a raison personne ne peut
dire le contraire s'ils voulaient c'est
une évidence
après il faut se poser la question
savoir va très bien on veut rien du
scalise est parfait comment on fait
alors premiers aidés on supprime les
impôts de production oui c'est la tarte
à la crème
sauf que ce que l'on oublie de dire
c'est que aujourd'hui l'état le budget
subventionne largement les entreprises
et elles les subventionnent bien plus
qu'elle ne les taxes sur la production
c'est le cic eux qui a été je dirais
consolider dans la loi de finances donc
déjà
est-ce qu'on veut aller plus loin dans
cette direction
et ça veut dire qu'on va faire des
entreprises des assistés deuxième point
réduire le coût du travail
très bien
mais là encore il faut savoir qu'est ce
que ça veut dire réduire le coût du
travail réduire le coût du travail
ces deux choses soit ça veut dire bon on
annonce aux français qu'on va réduire
leur salaire pour les français qui sont
dans la production qu'on va réduire leur
salaire de 20 à 25%
et ça il faut l'assumer devant devant
l'opinion
bon voilà on fait autre chose
on sort de l'euro on laisse la monnaie
se déprécier et par ces dépréciations
ont diminué au coût de 20 à 25%
mais là on voit bien ça pose un
véritable choix de stratégie économique
et de stratégie politique
après il ya une troisième idée tout le
monde va dire oui mais il faut
redévelopper à la productivité il faut
investir dans la recherche et le
développement
oui en fait tout le monde dit ça tout le
monde est d'accord là dessus mais est ce
qu'on a fait le calcul de ce qu'il
faudrait investir
que ce soit dans la production où que ce
soit dans les services publics qui d'une
certaine manière aide à la production
pour que la france compense des coûts
salariaux qui sont du fait de l'euro
plus haut de 20 à 25 % que chez nos
partenaires et bien en réalité ça veut
dire que sur cinq à sept ans il faudrait
investir régulièrement entre 50 et 70
milliards d'euros par an alors on voit
bien c'est pas le plan européen qui va
nous permettre de le faire le plan
européen il sera dépensée en moins de
deux ans et là encore se pose la
question de savoir où est-ce que
emmanuel macron pense trouver l'argent
pour aboutir à cela donc on le voit et
il y a quand même des incohérences en
matière de réflexion sur cette question
de la réindustrialisation de la france
pour conclure jacques sapir qu'est ce
qu'il faut retenir lors de cette
allocution
du président pour retenir plusieurs
choses la première chose
oui c'est une évidence le président est
rentré en campagne électorale en fait
cette allocution c'est le début de la
campagne électorale
mais il ya aussi peut-être une autre
chose qu'il faut retenir et qui n'est
pas moins important ce qui est manuel
macron semble avoir compris que la
réalité d'une économie
et bien c'est d'être complexe c'est
d'avoir une agriculture c'est d'avoir
une industrie c'est d'avoir des services
qui s'intègrent justement dans cette
agriculture et dans cette industrie
bref que l'économie française est tout
autre chose que cette fameuse start up
nation qui a été je dirais le mot
d'ordre simplificateur le mot d'ordre
simpliste d'emmanuel macron dans les
premières années de son mandat
après est-ce qu'il saura tirer toutes
les conséquences de ce choix qu'il fait
en faveur de l'économie française est en
faveur de l'industrie
ça c'est une autre histoire merci
jacques
vous suivra évidemment prochainement à
la rentrée on suivra tout ça dans les
mois à venir d'ici là bonnes vacances à
vous